[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
will ich habe auch heute wieder ein
advent special für euch am ersten advent
hat sich am tannenbaum gebacken den hier
alle fleißig nachgebacken habt und ihr
habt mir die fotos richtig schön auf
meine facebook pinnwand gepostet habe
mich wirklich seine freuen die bäume
sind wunderbar aus und heute habe ich
wieder ein ganz besonderes video für
euch und schaut euch mal an wer heute
höher gestellt hat in der manfred und
ich habe gedicht
achtung die stets vor und wieder über
romy kunst kommerz es gibt so grundstück
schon andere fights
die leitzinsen sind wie im rausch bei
dem bescheid pflicht geschenke austausch
es wird gehetzt gehetzt und gepackt
unheimlich gestrickt die
weihnachtsüberraschung bombe tickt leben
mach dich bereit
diese zeit ist normal verweigert geht
mir gewaltig of the tiger maiwald war
für mich zu beginn ein prächtiges tasche
aber ich finde mit fortschritt einer
lebensdauer wird ihr buttercreme an sich
und die sahne sauer halt diesen
historisch also und ist ganz gebacken
irgendwo gesundheitsamt witziger
ungelogen die waltraud aus dem verkehr
gezogen
studium apropos aus dem verkehr
ich sag's nicht kennen aber ich
sentimental ist hase heim habe war die
wahlkreisliste welt zum vergleich allein
nachts dort bestellt und mit welcher
story waltraud harley goss so guten
appetit schöne worte
so seien raum fred habe es wie gesagt
heute bei mir gestellt vielen dank
manfred ich möchte ich jetzt einfach mal
zeige ich mich in der weihnachtspause
mach ich habe mir überlegt dass ich eine
mini trainieren gestartet und möchte ich
in diesem video einfach mal die
einzelnen schritte zeigen dass ich auch
ziemlich aufwendig somit heute
herzustellen
deswegen habe ich euch in diesem video
ist die wichtigsten schritte
zusammengefasst und alles andere was ihr
dafür benötigt das sage ich euch dann
auch immer an der stelle
das bekommt die abos in der infobox als
linke eingesetzt und die infobox ist
hier unten
damit sei man auf info trinken und dann
stehen da die ganzen links mit drin also
immer wenn ihr uns wissen deutscher oder
erstmal da unten rein weil das
wichtigste drin steht und diese links
die ihr in der infobox findet das sind
die links zu meinen einzelnen videos auf
seinem youtube channel und da können das
alles ausführlich noch mal nachschauen
in der torte backen werde ist ein
lebkuchen teils und schoko lebkuchen mit
namen flammen füllungen und einer sagt
peter krämer und wie ihr den teig
herstellt was sie da sagen sondern
benötigt das eigentlich jetzt für den
teig braucht ihr sechs eier 200 gramm
puderzucker
ihr braucht 160 milliliter flüssigkeit
es kann trauben sagen oder pflaumen saft
oder irgendwas anderes sein ihr könnt
auch nur vornehmen
ihr braucht 120 gramm öl und ich möchte
es immer ganz gern im gramm ab weil ich
dann keinen messbecher braucht sondern
einfach das glas auf meine waage stelle
ihr braucht 50 gramm kakaopulver eine
packung backpulver 100 gramm
speisestärke 150 gramm mehl
ich habe jetzt hier meine gewürzmischung
ich habe hier zwei teelöffel zimt
dann habe ich hier einen halben
teelöffel ingwer gemahlen
hier habe ich etwas kardamom auch einen
halben teelöffel und hier habe ich zwei
zeit rückten elton und außerdem habe ich
da noch etwas muskatnuss reingeschrieben
gerade so etwa eine prise und wie immer
kommen jetzt zuerst die eier in einer
schüssel und während es schön verrührt
wird kommt dann noch der puderzucker mit
rein und es wird dann richtig schön
cremig gerührt
[Musik]
und wenn die eier masse dann so aussieht
ist er richtig bewegt und dann nehme ich
mir einfach ein und feinem haar sie und
gibt da die trockenen zutaten rein das
liegt einfach die klümpchen zu vermeiden
[Musik]
dann kommen da noch die gewürze rein und
noch öl und die flüssigkeit und es wird
jetzt einmal ganz schön dunkel
untergehoben hier habe ich mir jetzt
zwei backformen zurechtgelegt und zwar
sind es zwei mit dem gleichen
durchmesser die haben den durchmesser
von 20 zentimetern jeweils ihr könnt
natürlich auch eine große form nehmen 26
oder 28 form und in nur einer vom backen
oder eben die hälfte des rezepts dann
eben dieser einen kleinen form
ich möchte jetzt einfach dass meine
torte richtig schön hoch wird aber dass
ich jetzt auch nicht mehr ewig lange
backzeit habe packe ich das auch zwei
frauen
und so wird das ganze jetzt bei 175 grad
für etwa 30 minuten gebacken
es sollte auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe machen so setzt der kuchen
gebacken aus ich habe das jetzt ein
bisschen abgedeckt und habs abkühlen
lassen und jetzt werde ich hier den rand
entfernen und nehmen das ganze von
dieser folie runter und lass es richtig
schön abkühlen
wie gesagt reicht dieser teig für eine
große springform ich würde da so ohne 28
cm springform empfehlen oder ihr macht
eben das so wie bei mir in zwei
verschiedenen kleine förmchen damit es
eine hohe torte wird und wer keiner holt
orte traum und nur eine kleine braucht
daher wird eben den teig ich werde euch
jetzt im nächsten schritt zeigen wie ich
die show part meter kleben herstelle
die muss nämlich gleich nochmal
kaltgestellt werden deswegen müsst ihr
die ziemlich am anfang machen und die
creme zeige ich euch jetzt nur ganz kurz
wie gesagt setze ich euch den link hier
unten in die infobox da könnt ihr euch
noch mal die ganz genauen mengenangaben
anschauen und ich sage ich es einfach
mal ganz schnell wie ich diese creme
hersteller für die garage braucht ihr
200 gramm schlagsahne und 200
bitterschokolade falls er keine zeit
bitterschokolade mixed könnt ihr auch
vollmilchschokolade nehmen daneben da
aber bitte 300 gramm und die genauen
mengenangaben für ghanas und welches
verhältnis er mit anderer schokolade
braucht findet ihr auch in einem link
den ich euch unten in der infobox poster
und weil es natürlich viel schneller
geht mache ich meine
thermomed dazu gebe ich jetzt einfach
die sonne rein und lassen sie etwa drei
minuten bei 100 grad auf kochen so etwa
stufe 1 und sobald die sonne dann kocht
gebt ihr da die schokolade und dann
lasse ich das jetzt einfach verstehen
für etwa zwei bis drei minuten und werde
es dann später einmal durch nicht so
sollte die garagen aussehen und jetzt
will ich sie einmal um und stellen sie
kalt damit sie eben wieder fest wird die
garagen sind etwa eine stunde in den
kühlschrank die soll nämlich nicht zu
fest werden weil ich sehr schön
verstreichen will und ich werde jetzt
als füllung etwas pflaumenmus benutzen
und jetzt zeige ich einfach mal wie ich
die torte befülle und wie sie zusammen
setzte nach dem abkühlen nehme ich mir
meine tortenböden und die habe ich jetzt
hier am rand etwas gerade runter
geschnitten deswegen sieht es hier so
krümelig aus und jetzt werde ich die
einmal halbiert das habe ich jetzt hier
eine drehbare tortenplatte die eignet
sich immer super blick da meine kappe
platte drauf dass ich einfach so eine
leicht schauen platte die ich mit dem
cutter zurechtschneiden kann
und da gebe ich jetzt ein ganz klein
bisschen gar nach oben drauf so dass
einfach der boden jetzt drauf hält dann
kommt dort der erste boden drauf und
dann nehme ich mir etwas pflaumenmus und
gibt es mit hilfe von so einer winkel
palette da drauf
[Musik]
nach dem befüllen und orte muss sie
gestrichen werden und hirsch ist jetzt
ganz wichtig dass ihr die torte richtig
glas streicht weil ihr da nämlich eine
von der decke drauf legt und das eben
ganz hilfreich sein muss dass ihr eine
schöne glatte oberfläche habt wenn ihr
bei youtube ein gibt motiv torte oder
von damit orte kommt ihr direkt auch mal
der videos da zeige ich euch das alles
schritt für schritt und jetzt zeige ich
euch im schnelldurchlauf einmal wie ich
die torte bestreite und wie ich sie
danach mit sondern ein kleid
[Musik]
die grundlage habt ihr jetzt die torte
kommt jetzt in den kühlschrank kam dort
etwas feststellen der von land kann
austrocknen und jetzt müsst ihr einfach
noch die deko herstellen
die deko welches auch was von dort
machen und sag ich das jetzt im
einzelnen schritt für schritt die idee
könnt ihr entweder trocknen lassen dann
können dass ihr auch schon zwei wochen
vorher machen ihr könnt praktisch jetzt
schon starten für eure weihnachtskarte
oder ihr deckt somit etwas folie und
verein dann trocknet ihr euch nämlich
nicht aus und ihr könnt sie nur flexibel
um die torte herumlägen
ich sage ich dann nochmal meine
gestanden zwei spiele und hoffe dass
solche gefahren
[Musik]
geburtstag
dr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der beste teil
der breit
b
[Musik]
die
siegen
hmm
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt fertig ich habe
meine torte wie ihr gesehen habt noch
mit einem schlitten dekorierten habe ich
aus zucker hergestellt und auch diese
kleine geschenke waren aus zucker also
aus blüten passte da findet auch noch
meine wie youtube channel und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachbacken
ich hoffe dass da ein oder andere die
torte nach macht und dass ich euch dazu
inspirieren konnte wenn euch das video
gefallen hat dann teilt ihr mit euren
freunden lass mir ein kommentar oder
eine bewertung und wir sehen uns nächste
woche wieder oder gerne auch etwas
früher auch meine youtubetm besucht auch
meine website verließ torten welt.de
da findet ihr auch die ganzen rubriken
das ist mein job meine youtube-seite
meine facebook-seite und auch etwas über
mich was ihr uns nachlesen volt und
jetzt wünsche ich heute noch einen
wunderschönen den zweiten advent und
dann sehen wir uns nächstes mal wieder
[Musik]
ab 11
kiwi machen
[Musik]